yeah chin we're good yeah we're good God
cut my own hair yelling at us chin
yeah what dude cut my own hair again cuz
I'm part of a roll club as you know Oh
what I'm sorry yes I'm in an underground
roll club now roll yeah roll so you roll
what I grapple grappling that reduce if
grappling in general so [ __ ] it's it's
gross you're showing the faience of you
what must watch the fight this weekend
what was your favorite fight see here's
the thing who would you give Mac the
other night - ok hold on for a second I
was in a but just who was your favorite
how about Sean O'Malley I know you
believe he's our own man we got la mitad
crazy [ __ ] nuts so do this how about
cody government three fight [ __ ]
submit it to again
what's with this jujitsu [ __ ] huh guys
you believe a man a Nunez I couldn't
believe that but she want here's the
thing I was those guys well I was in
Huntington Beach and I was I was doing
my thing and with my kids we were
attacking the waves and yeah you all you
surf at night well well then we went to
a fish place okay friends his kids about
six o'clock
I talked to an ocean safety expert by
the way it's your hand on my face cuz
I'm well cuz I roll I don't care what
fish you've been hanging out as I roll
right so wrong so a grapple so I'm
getting less and less afraid of you I
really am I really am now I hate to do
this right now
what I'm staring at your hair yeah it's
annoying me yeah and him to ask me for
you not no no no now take there don't
say that you can see that I have a full
head of hair it's just not as thick as
it could be like yours you look like a
baby ostrich okay I don't like what you
said now let's say a couple things I
talked to an ocean scene a baby ostrich
yeah talk to an ocean safety expert
asking about rip tides and I got a
question about rip tides and I said art
don't forget to sharks okay so don't
fight him
chin what the [ __ ] man I'm just like
don't pull up baby ostrich man when I
[ __ ] appoint your day scroll down
hold your beak dude looks like that far
left the far left you guys are being see
that's kind of less that's disrespectful
that's [ __ ] districts around baby
ostrich not don't call me that
mm-hmm so anyway I uh
I was asking about riptides anybody out
there you get caught in a Riptide
it's not gonna pull you under you're
gonna be fine let it take you
I've already covered this I know let it
take you and then swim - swim diagonal
just roll I love ya then he said I got a
bone to pick with with shop with your
boy shop tell him that when you see
seals in the water
let me shark sure that means there are
no sharks and I go what he was yelling
i'ma go what do you mean because because
seals know when they're sharks and they
get the [ __ ] out of there so when you
see seals it's good news get in the
water hold on huh when seals are not
there it sketches [ __ ] you know does it
make sense yeah it does he's an expert
yeah he's a water next we're like Falchi
he's a water safety okay so let's talk
about full disclosure he's awesome folks
groceries just how I got its 22 oh wow
so you tell this 22-year old [ __ ] listen
Baywatch
yeah here's the thing what do you think
sharks eat what do you what are they
yeah they eat see us another fish they
eat seals right yeah
so when there's group of seals around
what do you think would bring the Sharks
near the seal now I agree with that
firstly if I see seals I'm getting I'm
not going anywhere near that but this
ocean safety expert is 22 is a lifeguard
Reese wait you know what oh god I hate
to do this to my baby watch [ __ ] dude
Kelly hey watch [ __ ] I'm sorry I like
that listen a little bit he's gotta easy
easy
he's got a very very thick and blond
boys skinny and black you can be very
light goes to things too thick okay so
he's all assam tip well get them a bike
and shut the [ __ ] up here's the thing
Kelly Slater told me seal you'll be
worried about it no huh sir yep surface
told me this Nathan
yep this skis 22 yeah you've got on your
Tropicana suntan lotion okay and you
shut okay you're young but sunblock is
super blond no he's blond yeah you know
low key blues son oh I know him yeah
great kid I love him to death
he's a lifeguard in the oh he was a
lifeguard for a guy like a Long Beach Oh
doesn't count
I know I know it the gay lobby what the
[ __ ] yeah thank you [ __ ] yeah he's like
say nothing you tell me schmuck now so
blue eyes that's blue eyes he looks like
the lead
antiva listen no he's mentally durante
for not as he looks like it
no cuz they're they're they're
anti-fascist I know but they look like
him no they're not that blonde blue eyes
amar
he looks more like Hitler Youth he's on
of course he's hella would protect him
yes he's like the point is you're too
thick to be a lifeguard quick turn
shuffle lifeguard also your dad's
station and we're cuz that Costanza's
don't worry about oh yeah different
places but he's also near Iraq huh how
much life Gardens going on oh he was
here at hunting he grew up always David
and Monterey were there a lot of great
whites not agree with there was a great
white attack right oh yeah recently like
yesterday
oh yeah Hayek right no bring up no the
guy died in the shark took off and then
I go well let's save that guy in the
sharklet well what's this [ __ ] is this
so smiley is here in Australia yep
suffered dies after me a bit my great
white shark nearly 10 feet long and
those people go well let's save the guy
in the shark went well there's more
targets and you start chasing them is
that true oh my god that scared the [ __ ]
out of me waiting a.m. on Sunday Oh
shark swimming on to Costa 50 old males
benefit attacked by shirt
you think the blame on corona damn
curler [ __ ] man do we stop wearing masks
on can you make it I'm not surfing there
I know it's rare I'm still not surfing
there there's gotta have drones can't
they have drones to just look for this
[ __ ] all the time they do what do you
that's their home I know I know it's
true they're like don't swim here that
cuz that we saw a shark but come back
tomorrow like the Sharks a big [ __ ]
shark yeah I guess they jumped on a
while to save the guy in the shark went
Oh what do we have here isn't it weird
when people jump in the water save
together the Sharks like this is too
easy
oh there's a handful of fatal shark
shark attacks in Australia alright yeah
yeah we want to be careful of that we
just do was just video of it well
there's a forest curiosity right but if
there's also yeah it's so scary it's so
scary things bigger than the jet ski no
thanks by the way that's only ten feet
you got old gray and get up to 25 that's
a babe
okay that's 25 feet whoa what an April a
shark fatally mauled a 23 old wildlife
worker on the Great Barrier Reef again
there the reef is not good
have you know how they have odds
obviously all statistics are skewed but
if you're like you're more likely hit by
lightning than dying don't care a shark
will hold on you're more likely to get
hit by lightning and die from Corona if
you're under 36 no underlying health
conditions that's a real one but you're
more like yudish your odds go up if
you're surfing there every day the odds
are worse they do so for all those
surfers like dude you're more like
you're dying the way driving here mm-hmm
if you live in the water your odds go
water for like you and me I haven't been
the beach but maybe the reason they're
so rare is cuz we don't spend a lot
human beings don't spend a lot of time
in the water especially cold water where
there are great whites unless you're a
surfer you know and then you're on a
board and all that but you know I would
imagine if you're swimming around all
the time something's gonna happen yeah d
am I ready to go it'd be a bad way to go
I mean if there are seals they do take
off so there was a guy who got his leg
bitten off by a great white he was he
was scuba diving with seals and he said
and all of a sudden they just
disappeared they just all went to me
they scattered he's alone he was that's
weird
says cuz old gray came in and went oh
yeah well he 24 I'll take that well he
thought yeah guide and give me that leg
long time god damn that is very scary
there's something about being in the
water you can't ask this question and I
know the answer but it'll get us
somewhere sure did you see who did you
see the Bruce Lee documentary BB water I
did not see the glue say doctor have you
watched the last days your ass last
dance yet uh no because did you see the
Lance Armstrong one no those are two
things but I'm going to now here's the
thing what you say you do I've seen be
water I haven't seen me water because
it's gonna get I feel like it's
documentary about an actor but I know
it's more than that it's so it's gonna
get well it's he when I was watching it
that's why I want to ask you watch it
cuz I wasn't watching it after my girl I
go Bryan's gonna see this and it's gonna
validate his point you know he's a
childhood act you
no doubt stiii need good when he was
four he certainly the Chinese certain
right or that was Jackie Chan actually I
was chair you know his dad his dad was a
business and his dad put him in movies
he had like speaking when always like
four but he grew up as a child actor
star John star yes he did he died when
he was 18 there he went to San Francisco
I'm sorry when he was like two months
ago they came back since then he came
back to Hong Kong cook yep and then
started movies and then and they came
over here to try making the movies he's
acting his whole life whole life and
then he then what sorry it wasn't his
somebody in this family was white am I
wrong his wife his mom his wife no is he
is he he's white as well yeah yeah his
mom eyes next yes but his mom's not all
white she's mixed okay yeah she's like
half asian half white and add straight
up hunk from Chinese okay four-time got
but uh yes so but so he was huge over
and huge oh yes the song is like I'm
making Hollywood goes to Hollywood
doesn't go great for him he did get it
he didn't land on the the Green Hornet
yep I remember it's crazy how he got the
Green Hornet he was doing a
demonstration in Long Beach and there
was a stylist there a haircut Stas it
was like oh this guy's great and he cuts
the hair of this big guy who owns I
think Warner Brothers he was getting the
guy who made a decision that Warner
Brothers and because I know you look for
an Asian actor fill the Quito or with
taquito Kato can title role this guy
might be good they bring him in and they
show his audition Jesus Christ
really well they didn't realize since he
was four he's been in front of the
camera oh yeah so they thought he was
just gonna be doing this dude they bring
him in and he's um they bring him some
why can't he just show some of your
moves and he just knows what he's doing
and it's like but he's so like quicken
they've never seen any but it's I mean
quick but he's so like entertaining it
cuz he's doing it he's talking he has
dropping these philosophical lines on
there like Jesus Christ so he gets that
and then the rings weren't going good if
you've ever watched him I've watched I
think I've watched every one of his
episodes I use to be obsessed it he
didn't have a lot of lines a lot of
times he's just sitting there doing
karate he wrote to that he wrote to the
director was a cake
it should be good this he's not a
sidekick he's they're a team he should
have more lines they gave him some lines
when you realized the racism he died
god it's not oh my god here see how they
describe an Asian person in Breakfast at
Tiffany's
ha ah ma they're doing this that's what
and we believe with his girlfriend the
time is soon to be wife after that who
was white they went then he's like what
the [ __ ] dude oh it's so bad so so bad I
always have this super suspect super
suspect his son who died I know what
we're not the biggest conspiracy
theorists but when you look into that
even a son who Brandon Lee who died look
at that yeah I know that's a white guy
pretend to be that's what they usually
did it's so humid day you know even in
his son Brandon Lee says you know he's
murdered by the the Chinese mafia and so
he likes it didn't the the excuse that
he was allergic to aspirin that makes
sense because his father took aspirin
his entire life I don't know I don't
know now he did get his sweat glands
take it out because he didn't like how
much you sweat on camera get sweat
through his pits and sustain his shirt
because sweating so much so you got
those taken out is that true no we can
do for that yes a week before he died he
had he passed out because it's so hot
because he got sweat glands removed and
so when he died it was the hottest day
of the year knees doing all this stuff
are you sure he had a sweat clay I don't
some things were true strange but true
sweat glands rumors under pits according
reports Lee didn't have them removed for
any medical reasons or kids from
excessive sweating he did because I
camera like that we also got circumcised
that I think 18 or 19 20 22 well that's
weird
why because you wanted more merit more
American yeah now y'all so you know I
got all these weird rabbit holes where I
want the dark stuff about these people
so apparently he also liked the women he
did like the way most famous guy in
China that's right and then that's
surprising they asked him if you have
any like either go you know like be with
your fame you know a lot of temptation
and he goes he said I forget the exact
line but he goes you know I I was bad
but I wasn't as bad as a lot of other
does well he was 33 than when he died 32
okay so as young as [ __ ]
at the top of his game and yes and a
handsome every every woman liked him so
yes up some woman drop wrote a book how
she was his sidepiece I believe that
really laid down the best dick game in
the world to like that every girl he's
had sex was like used to the best I've
ever had
[Music]
experimenter pleasers it's a good point
so our women know so it's kind of you
know we're giving people great people
yeah it's a fast thing he was a pioneer
and it was acceptable to be essentially
derogatory and racist or whatever toward
Asian people certainly in my lifetime
certainly up through the 80s and I'm not
making excuse me
you also got to realize the Japanese
they were enemy right her Harbor so my
tag one other's Korean I mean I remember
like he would the way people would treat
you is just um you guys I mean you guys
are young but I'm sure you tell it but
your parent wasn't ready to Paris for
shortly yeah being in Texas mean not
biggest crane in the world did you toss
that was a chubby and small back then so
slowly worse yeah yeah do you deal with
it can I feel like no one [ __ ] it at um
where I grew up I mean as long as we're
willing to fight like it's fine
Vietnamese from what correct me if I'm
wrong a lot of times Vietnamese and the
Cambodians in the Kansas country will
gang up they'd be a being they'd run in
in groups and if you were gonna fight
them they were gonna fight you yeah
there's a lot of people who don't like
interact with Vietnamese people or
Cambodian people don't know is that
we're small people but we're feisty and
we're down in a fight Oh biggest thing
we're like little people feel like you
don't have the personnel you get fun you
know sometimes a person how do you think
I feel like no oh no I never want to
fight with anybody but I think the voice
like kind of sets people off cuz they
see me and they're like oh she's young
yeah and then I have like a deep bass
voice like oh no Koreans don't take any
[ __ ] either it's the ethnic Chinese who
have done so incredibly well because
their culture and by the way so of the
Chinese so of the Vietnamese that they
suffered no shortage of racism but they
have crushed it to the point where
obviously places like Harvard have a
class that they're harvesting like we
can't have this many Asians we gotta
think what else is interesting there's
there's racism inside Asia of quite
Chinese towards Koreans Japanese towards
Koreans well so so this guy John Glover
Dan Glover who was a CIA contractor when
he was he was talking on on on this
podcast he was saying when I was my
mother is Korean
his dad's
when he was and then he had his buddy
who was a Japanese American he had his
dad was Japanese mom was happy Japanese
and she said to him she's Korean she
goes you have to beat him you have to
beat him in every score like there was a
rivalry just with that
that shit's heavy that should hello I'm
sorry groups human beings are tribal no
matter what you'll never get rid of the
racism yogi or you you might get rid of
a sysm will beat rival we could be the
same exact you could be the same exact
look exactly there's as teams everyone
Tilak but but there's a box within
whites and whites talk to Nigerians talk
to you Yoruba and an ebow talk to ebooks
about how they feel about euro bus talk
to West Indians about how they feel
about American blacks talk to Africans
people from Africa who come here and how
they feel about people an average back
from Mississippi you've got to have a
conversation a candid one human beings
are this way so this idea that that
racism is yes with the systemic races
are we have a legacy of racism yes we're
dealing with the wreckage of our past
100% but please understand please
understand human beings are tribal I
think I think it's interesting with like
because of Drew Brees the and you saw
Roger Goodell the owner of the NFL the
Commission and I fell not the owner but
the Commission I felt come out and he
put out a video saying we did mess up we
didn't handle the peaceful protest that
cop he didn't say cap Nick but that the
players were don't know why didn't say
Kevin X name would do them so much more
justice but he said you know what
Kaepernick was doing the peaceful
protests we handled that we should have
we apologized we made mistakes I mean
they came out right away to get in front
of it right away but what's interesting
is you and you tell you do be so let's
say you're the owner of the Los Angeles
Rams and you're your court your starting
quarterback wants taking me and let's
say it's it's this coming season he goes
Brian I know you the head coach or you
the owner of the team I'm gonna take
your knee and you're the owner and it's
you run a business
now when and I don't have the answer I
don't know the answer and I think it's
fine cabinet can do what he wants to do
let's just leave it from bottom dollar
standpoint the NFL when they went
through all that stuff the views and
everything was down 20%
20 percent loss now when you talk about
you're talking about billions and
billions dollars twenty percent of
billions dollars is a lot of money it's
when politics and people take knees for
the flag in the NFL the viewership is
down 20% what what do you do so for me
20% so for me this is what I do I put
all the responsibility on my players in
terms of this you're a free you're a
free American part of what is beautiful
about the flag is that you can you can
fly it from your house or you can burn
it and not go to jail yeah and that is
in endemic to the flag that is the that
is the nature of like if you are a
starting quarterback and you feel you
want a kneel in front of everybody and
deal with those consequences which are
going to be they're going to be economic
consequences they're going to be social
consequences they're also going to be
social pluses they're also going to be
economic pluses for me I would take a
completely hands-off approach and I
would say can you do it my players are
free Americans if you want an eel and
protest which is if you think about
kneeling for the flag it's actually a
rather interesting because I believe
when Kaepernick did it he was just it
was his way of doing it in a very subtle
non violent West his way of bringing
attention into that right it's like a
sit-in so for me he was it kneeling
because of America he is dealing due to
the fact that he thought bringing light
to police brutality towards African
America and you told me I think that he
consulted a Navy SEAL and said the seal
said don't sit if you take a knee yes
it's more respectful correct so for me
Kaepernick was trying to ride that
bounce took a lot of guts
I don't know Kaepernick I don't know
anything about him I don't know anything
about him but I do think that not but
here's my thing if I'm the owner and you
want to take the stance the the your
ships going to have 20 percent okay so
cap and I paid a price for this
now I know he made money later on but
but Kaepernick was willing to put a cap
a price he didn't know and maybe but
there was a gamble regardless right so
when you do that Kaepernick took
responsibility and said I'm gonna do
that he lost his job in one way in the
NFL but he also made a lot more money
the other way maybe instead we but I bet
you he wasn't sure of that that's never
a guarantee it could have been that
he just could have been [ __ ] destitute
who knows and then he could have done a
speaking tour with liberal colleges or
something but what I respect about it
was that the man said I'm gonna take the
ramifications the consequences come as
they may positive and negative but this
is what I believe I'm gonna kneel so for
me I'd never make them stay in the
locker room does a bad idea I would just
say if you want to do that you're a free
American and the flag is a symbol of
freedom if that's your choice as a free
American go ahead but understand that
there's always a reaction and understand
that reaction is not gonna be a positive
one for a lot of people now I may take a
hit but the thing about that is I don't
know if it's my place to tell even my
employees even my employees and let me
let me let me let me capitalize on this
for a second if I own a corporation or a
company and somebody and we're watching
a game and and the national anthems up
and a bunch of people stand but one
person sits I don't think I should have
the right to force him to stand because
he works in my company agree and I also
don't feel like I have the right to
penalize him you know because if he if
he's a competent worker you're not right
because now I'm penalizing him for his
book but it's a little bit like saying
you're feels I can't have you in my
house he's a little difficult because
it's not he's not Jimmy Garoppolo is
what a way better player yes so when I
remember what do I'm saying so as far as
Exynos he's does gazoo now you're
talking here for me so now you're
talking my company but here's the other
thing be so yeah what would you have
chin in here if every time we just from
pure business standpoint if every time
we did current events chin picked the
worst current event and his take on
things drop the viewership 20% would you
keep chin around because no because we
knew you and I would have to have a
conversation with Chen say hey Chen like
the way you and I - so when I was doing
dropping knowledge for whatever reason
people stopped listening and we saw that
yeah so and we had to change we had to a
chest you know and so I'd say this chin
we have to adjust because we're losing
ratings here this is weird just do a
better job I know it's what you think is
good but we have a different so we have
another same conversation with Colin
cabinet and
I'm a little bit of a
I'm saying different but tough cuz
they're a different approach because if
you and this is something that Clayton
Travis mentioned I think it's it's a
little bit of a band-aid over the the
problem but I can see where he's going
with it and I'm gonna give my ideas on
it so he goes especially doing right now
quarantine all this you know people were
in masks which is ridiculous but
everyone doing those things what if you
know especially in the NBA there's not
gonna be an audience there's not gonna
be not in the NBA so you're not gonna do
the at six six from North Carolina
Michael Jordan and everybody just the
players are clapping you know I can
introduce everybody so you probably not
gonna do the national anthem during that
so there's really not an opportunity
there to protest or make a stance to
anything and the you'll see there's no
national anthem there's too many
there's too much they don't do any of it
do any of it so in the NFL even though
it's it's America's sport more people
watch the Super Bowl then the World
Series Game seven
NHL MLS everything combined more people
watch the Super Bowl more than a Super
Bowl or super balls King but then I felt
king by far they destroy everybody so if
you take away the national anthem the
ratings drop overall or does he get rid
of their platform to take us protest
during that time a really good question
I personally love tradition and I love
the national anthem and I love the fact
that we play it before games I
absolutely love it in the other day and
I love my country but I hold I love my
country too but you like it at
everything you go to I don't know I know
I don't know I know that's an American
tradition for most games isn't it for
baby when you played ball did they play
the national anthem before you play it
yeah I just personally like it but I
gotta tell you I like it because it
symbolizes again with you if he's
reading missed it in the UFC no I don't
um so so so would this is not new for us
you guys a little bit too young to
remember but when Herbert Walker Bush
the first Bush was in office there was a
flag burning debate in this country
because some people that were burning
flags and and I don't like with that so
George Herbert Walker Bush went toward a
[ __ ] American flag Factory and said
he has such a
great feeling and you know personally he
wouldn't allow it but and then we and
while I was at work at Lehman Brothers I
was you know and we were having this
huge fight and some guys like alright
you got your right to burn the flag then
I got about to crack your [ __ ] head
and I'm like huh guys this is that
you're missing the point
the point is that this is a great
country flash replication yeah we you
it's a great country because you can't
prosecute somebody for [ __ ]
exercising their right even if it is
unpatriotic in your eyes and it all goes
back to the same thing when if you start
telling people if you start firing
people for kneeling well look there are
people who have very offensive political
views sometimes right so say I'm with a
bunch of people and I work with them and
I find out that this two dudes are
active members of the Communist Party
and actively working legally but
actively working and doing everything
they can even if they're pushing on the
boards of the legality to to get rid of
anybody who's a conservative Republican
or a libertarian they just believe in
massive state control and a
redistribution of property to me that's
a very dangerous destructive idea
Marxism I can't stand it but I don't
have a right I have a right to debate
them I have a right not to spend time
with them I have a right to criticize
them but I don't have a right to fire
them for their beliefs because if we go
down that road now I'm not that because
they could sue me
because and they should rightfully be
able to sue me because they're
exercising their freedom with that I'll
stop and it's on then I felt that fire :
captain right then went right he's not
playing the bass jar 20% object you
better be careful if you're gonna do it
right because if you're a superstar and
repercussion if you're if you're
American then FL you know they're trying
to appeal to the masses sure and I met
what the one thing I think the masses
especially in America Society doesn't
get down with this disrespect of the
flag a hundred percent I think if you
voted on that if you let me say
something no one agrees right and let me
say something else it is within the
right of Colin Kaepernick to kneel it is
also within the right of the owner of
that team to say that's not acceptable
when you work from my organization just
like George Steinbrenner said
when you work for the Yankees you shave
you never have a beard you keep your hat
on now
that [ __ ] was a dress code there was a
protocol that a corporate protocol in
Italy they you sign a dotted line on a
beard
yes now it is also within the rights of
that owner in my opinion to say you're
fired
Altice or your bestest histy now it's
also then within the rights of the
public of someone whoever it is to say
to pick it to put pressure on him to to
even lambaste him or whatever it is and
say you're an [ __ ] and all that you
you it's in your right to protest not
violently but you can protest that
decision too so we live in a society
where everyone has the ability to
exercise their right and even petition
their own government to even organize
politically and say to their government
it put pressure on politicians to do
your bit now agent Peter and said if
they play the national anthem
everybody's gonna take you me Adrian
Peterson said man he goes we're all
gonna do ok ok this is America and so
the dance goes and so the dance goes
this is not new to our republic guys
it's not new none of this is new to our
republic people taken in the streets her
soul what if would have been a better
idea of Colin Kapernick held a flag and
had all the names of the people that
were murdered who were unarmed the black
Americans who were unarmed who got
murdered he held a flag with all the
names on it would have that done more
and got the message morning that's the
major the the his idea of taking a knee
to shine light on police brutality got
overshadowed by him disrespect exactly
and that was this would have been
significant calculation I don't know who
knows but I love it with the 20% of
dropped off he would have done that I
don't know I love that we're talking
about this and I'm gonna take heed for
saying this but I really believe this in
my heart I think we as a country and I'm
talking about everybody and and I'll
make a point for this I think we are as
white people forget everybody else as
white people I think white people are
way less racist way less racist than
they were 20 years ago
way less racist than were 30 years ago I
think way that is back you up over the
back of this fast would 100 back you up
my kids my kids don't even know what the
[ __ ] that is
my children are very aware that that the
world needs to be a diverse place
schools have done an amazing job I was
raised by in schools I was raised and
all my friends were and I know you were
too that you don't ever judge somebody
for the color of their skin it makes no
sense scientifically mathematically
morally it's a ridiculous way to live so
we have made progress with may progress
no thanks to me but thanks to a lot of
people who put their lives on the line
and everything else I don't think
defunding the police is the answer you
see Minneapolis that's a tricky right
well but also it's it's also a
triggering word for people because
defunding doesn't mean you get rid of
the police never get rid of please and
there's been cities that have defined a
place Leeson murder was right the right
wing wants that yeah murder went through
the roof yeah yeah but remember when you
see fun hasta means taking money that
you were gonna give the police not
giving really police fine taking money
from them put in other stuff like
education home like there's other stuffs
so let me let me just it's a it's
basically taking the money from the
police yeah not getting rid of the
police but taking money from them put an
other Avenue let me let me context gonna
help this is not defunding the police
has not knew this this idea is not a
left-wing idea it's actually a lot of
right wing a lot of conservatives
libertarians actually believe in this
too
not because they don't want a strong
police force because the police unions
are very very strong very good at
organizing and they get very good
benefits because they're very
politically active they're very
politically active in local politics or
more to the LAPD that's when you defund
by a hundred and fifty million dollars
what we're really talking about and this
has been floating around this is always
tried but it's politically precarious
but this is an opportunity you want to
take those programs put them in the Boys
and Girls Clubs
you want to take those programs and put
them in crime drug prevention programs
there's a lot of those programs are
underfunded where the police because
they are very strong Union organized
those are that's sometimes I'm sorry
guys and I have a lot of
back for the cops it's a little over
funded and you know it and in fact when
you look at pension plans when you look
at pension plans and you can relight
tired 45 with full benefits in your
whole family can a lot of times some
towns don't have that tax base to
support that over and over and if you
disagree with me please see Stockton
California and I can give you a whole
list of a [ __ ] defund the police in
LA New York certain areas it's a bad
idea because if you think you have a
problem now with cops
if you defund these cops so that means
maybe now if you don't have those
incentives and they don't have those
401ks and those plans when they retire
you're not gonna get the smartest
brightest cops becoming cops you need
some bad apples ok Tommy now realize
wrong I don't think people realize
number one how hard that job is how well
a lot of cops do how how different it
would be if we didn't have such a
professional pull-offs when you say how
hard is that's the reason why they have
those retirement plans do you want to do
what they want to do there's our buddy
joseph azim loves to be a police officer
it's one of the best people I know and
you know my father-in-law retires in
four years even a cop for 30 years yeah
and and and he I'm sure he's a great cop
and but he also risked his life every
day seems to defund those guys you're
going down a weird road it's it's a very
very special markets like LA and New
York yes this is a really I don't like
the words defund the fun police or
automatic he gets all of us kind of like
wait a minute what it sounds very
erratic I'm gonna go by gun yes what I
would suggest is defund the police means
that the good the cops are allocated a
lot of money politically on Minneapolis
Minneapolis time about defunding and and
this take way very did that now you got
a City Council full of very liberal very
probably not the smartest people on the
planet who are really you know yeah and
and what are you gonna do you want to
take so there's a reason police forces
are in place these people know things if
you - you know good police forces and
cops they study crime like science and
and and they use technology and these
police officers they know [ __ ] it's just
like anything else they know [ __ ] that
you would never even think about yeah
but but off you back off as long as
you're following lost 30 years he knows
[ __ ] that you and I have no there at new
in details if you want to rethink it you
want a City Council to rethink
but think about who said a lot of a lot
of celebrities like you know John Legend
and his wife or like let's defund the
police let's just but I don't give a
[ __ ] about that one to put a hold on
blunt
so they're saying this let's different
they're not gonna be affected by it at
all because they're hiring private
security and off-duty police officers
that protect them no [ __ ] so left a fun
place so they can't help out I don't
give a [ __ ] about Hollywood celebrities
and and if they're talking including
probably me and I'm not a Hollywood
celebrity if Hollywood celebrities like
John Legend and Christy Teegan are
talking I don't give a [ __ ] yeah there's
really almost shouldn't count there it
doesn't count well because they're in
Beverly Hills and then they're saying
'die fun place but it's not gonna decide
can affect their lives at all cuz
they're high in private security which
most the time are off-duty police office
if you're a [ __ ] politician and you
got an and everybody starts Beyonce and
jay-z and John Legend and [ __ ] Robert
Downey jr. whoever it might be comes out
in support of you it might be the worst
thing for you because Americans
immediately go those people don't live
my lifestyle
hey you're you're their couch with a
bunch of Hollywood celebrities sipping
five five thousand-dollar bottle might
get the [ __ ] out here you don't know my
problems [ __ ] and usually it
works against John I could have to deal
with it huh they're not gonna feel a
stand Hollywood yeah I can't stand how
fickle it is it was transgender it was
me - it was kovat and now it's and now
it's [ __ ] uh racism these people are
like you never see a cat chasing a light
beam yeah here see how I triplets are
not powder is that color the way they're
like that man like that so I don't give
a [ __ ] about these fickle people I don't
give a [ __ ] cuz they'd go with
whatever's popular they don't have any
they don't really know that yeah no
[ __ ] have a back we get the [ __ ] out
it I don't get hey make me [ __ ] laugh
sing songs dance do what the [ __ ] you
know that that's what we do did the
don't start getting to your you're too
self-involved shut up and dribble no I
know you have your right you have your
right you have your right to say
whatever you want but I wish Christy
Teegan and [ __ ] John Legend had given
instead of giving money to bailout
protesters I wish they had given money
that $200,000 to a small minority-owned
business to bail them out never to a
poor family something who really needs
it but that's there
that's their right it's my right to
criticize them it's their right to do it
I literally just had my Omaha Steaks oh
you know you should get your dad for
Father's Day what some beef for his
mouth I had some for my mouth yesterday
I had that they had the they had the
Jumbo Franks which frankly were
delicious Oh relax I don't like where
you're going with this and I had the
steaks I had say the steak I had was a
filet mignon even though they said it
was a it was a they didn't say it was
filling me no but it looked like a filet
mignon I ate that it was delicious oh my
it's a family-owned company and they'll
actually send it to you in a box they
sent it in a big car uh I'm sorry
styrofoam box and then I got an apple
pie potatoes au gratin I got four
hamburgers six hot dogs I think four
steaks
it was unbelievable it was really really
good now they got a limited time
Father's Day offer so you can go to
Omaha Steaks dot-com enter the code
fighter in the search bar say 55% on the
gift dad will love for $79.99 your gift
will include like basically all the meat
if you paid for that in a restaurant
realistically it would cost you five
hundred thousand dollars because you're
at least five hundred bucks - dude four
four naturally lean top sirloin steaks
hand-carved and aged for at least 21
days for tenderness and flavor
mmm just had one last night delicious
it's all right for premium boneless
chicken breasts for dome a jumbo Franks
or glasses oh my god a package of savory
all beef meatballs for your mouth for
perfectly browned potatoes au gratin for
made from scratch caramel apple tarte
latex heart delicious and the Omaha
Steaks signature seasoned packet and get
all that in this Father's Day gift set
dad we'll get all this meat in his mouth
plus less free pound of steak cut bake
oh my god your dad's gonna freak out Oh
less than 80 bucks
do it that's actually a great game oh my
god 80 bucks man $39.99 the Father's Day
gift that keeps on giving go to Hamas
Omaha Steaks com type in fighter in the
search bar and saves 55 percent when you
send the summer sizzle pact for $79.99
and get a free steak cut bacon with your
order still
don't wait go to oma stay calm type
fighter in the search bar to order the
summer sizzle pack forefathers died set
it's delicious head underwater heads on
the water and you miss him did you see
fights this week in love duty can I tell
you I went [ __ ] six to six to twelve
my dick did cuz I'm so excited about
Phoenix this weekend I am Ciro come on
give me a pound I'm that brother hey
brothers hey alright so there is our
other brother gonna be there he shoves
ah brothers the brothers are back the
brothers are back together huh getting
our [ __ ] out in that [ __ ] Airbnb the
three of us and then and we're like hey
my like hey you know [ __ ] Chappelle
pull out your day what's your Panther
tells them yeah and then we got our
dicks out just running around drinking
beer I laugh and pushing each other down
I'll drink beer with you yeah you drink
whiskey pushing each other down you're
like drunk and you're like I'm [ __ ]
wrong and we're like run for the bear Oh
cocky on the baby Austria now now open
up baby bird you're the second Avenue
you know the second basa
maybe the best athlete in that house is
I know you think it's Rishabh been
chopped Chappelle's to 35 and can do
backflips and double back now that's
crazy how much mighty blade will pro
athlete
I'm just saying number estimate how much
money do you make is a profit I'll just
sit ok but then Moloch how much weight
he make is a pro yeah hundred ninety
amateur fights amateur
I'm saying dude don't teach don't sleep
or no I love you Tyler
oh well populated with the big boys Papa
swam with the great white uh-huh yeah
there one slipped inside I said it
brother I said around one time I go
we're talking about this guy who's
[ __ ] like tough to me he's like
[ __ ] me I go how would you do against
him that's so many he gets in my face
were walking I don't know Brad I imagine
I do really well because I fought for a
living he never he never competed once I
forgot about that detail but say you
know you're not in the world's never
compete it the moral of that story is
don't ever put your face in my face like
that again ok I'm glad I found
baby ostrich do you have you seen the
videos of Phoenix it is pop and that you
need they show like the clubs and the
bars it's pop I can't wait
and then well we just got this one of
the reason that brought up I just got a
text from our agent goes good news
Phoenix open up even more so we had all
six or seven shows are sold out and
we're at I think 260 capacity they
helped everything 300 every show added
40 tickets so yes it's right now Phoenix
yes come on come on hit by now for me
chill let's see if they updated it
because you couldn't get any tickets we
have three shows on Saturday San Antonio
I think all of them opened the tickets
yep oh by the way San Antonio lol
heyguys LOL do me a favor don't say I'm
gonna be there in August on your website
you since I'm gonna be there
June 25th 26th 27th maybe change your
website maybe change your website yep so
they buy tickets I got to piss out of my
dick I mean yeah it's cuz coke so what
you did when you were 17 is you can
never run away from when you were 50 cuz
you're the same person you had [ __ ]
ear I wear a beanie on Phoenix you know
you're a little heads you know part well
I don't look good in hats so that's
where beanie dude you look like you know
my neck is thick don't say that you look
like Joe Pesci um no head gets burned my
role and if I wear a beanie it's gonna
be a tasteful beanie that's gonna make
oh yeah I don't like the way you're
talking it's making me angry
the actors are 45 days later we incur
that's already we can do this one first
just I do it again so Ken now we're just
talking about this past thing with Mark
Wahlberg 1988 what's going on I teen 88
well 1986 was the first one so what
happened so he posted about George Floyd
and this is his post right here the
murder of George Boyd is heartbreaking
we must all work to fix the problem I'm
praying for all of us god bless okay
and then people place matter people
recall when he used to do racist things
back when his younger and it's kind of
part it's pretty bad in 1986 when he's
15
court documents state that Wahlberg was
among a group of white boys to arrest a
group of black 4th
Raiders in Boston were on a field trip
to beach by chasing him down the street
throwing rocks on racial slurs case 15km
1988 15 1988 a separate more severan
occurred when he did time behind bars
for being a Vietnamese shopkeeper in
2016 here are 17 / case of beer the
actor served 45 days of a two-year
sentence he has since apologised what's
the problem here
I mean he's young and made stupid yeah
horrible the skates when he was he said
woody something now and he was a Boston
kid okay and now no he's well is he 50
now cool so you want so whatever you did
I'll see here's the problem though this
this comet which who gives a flying [ __ ]
about cops but I don't really care who
it is it doesn't make him any exception
if you're racist you're always going to
be racist no wow here's the problem Wow
well there's the problem why are we
marching to change everything either so
do you think it changed our mind
why are you March and for him to want to
erase it I do think it's wrong Christian
Atwood you're a dumb-dumb
oh it's one of the victims of Wahlberg's
1986 attack attack get the [ __ ] out of
here
your thesis is that you're a [ __ ]
dummy but what they did so they want to
lose this critic of course there's no
apology what you did at 15 when you were
a minor before you could vote or
anything you should be punished for the
rest of your life Brandon why don't you
just kill him it's the same thing you
[ __ ] but these are morons these people
are so certainly there's learned there
literally ups up beside you learned from
Drew Brees so drew Brees makes that
thing where he goes you know
disrespecting the flag you messed up
there and then he's like oh [ __ ] I
didn't realize it educate himself was
like I messed up their issues an apology
his teammates like right that's fine
even though everyone still wants to kill
drew Brees then Trump goes I actually I
wish drew Brees didn't apologize then
drew Brees goes at Trump like no no
you're misinformed I was misinformed
you're misinformed so now he's an app
he's a much bigger advocate for black
lives matter if you mean the enemy in
glasses yeah because he learned
something and he got a perspective
minded he got a perspective cuz you can
change few [ __ ] dummies but we
shouldn't be talking about morons like
this because they're so stupid they're
so stupid and they're so they don't like
people and they don't want change what
they want their scene
people love having an enemy if you take
an enemy away from certain groups and
activists they don't have anything to do
they lose their job they need racists
they and if they can't find racists they
will make racist stuff people did this
is what happens if you if you are an
activist and that's your entire identity
and take a look at some of these
activists they're not stable people one
shall not happen well they're a mess
they never get laid
I'm not saying activists are all this
way I'm saying that when you see these
people who are just unforgiving they're
not all there these are these people are
psychologically very questionable and
they're cruel and they're not good
people so so they're gonna find their
whole identity is wrapped around this
fight take the fight away it's a big
problem it's exactly like in a
revolution when you have a militia and
they start what happens after every
revolution with the exception of the
American Revolution they [ __ ] they
they they they break up into two
factions and they start fighting for
power exactly what what happened with
the foot bro put the foot Babybird no my
feet are pretty baby bands my feet tires
bro well no you're wearing light at half
i wear ten and a half tiger worse than I
have I work 10 really enough I work 10
hours Papa I work 10 that say it again
baby bird you got to be careful cuz I
baby you and I feel like I might go surf
and turf I'll [ __ ] you up Monday if you
want [ __ ] up Monday no it's not [ __ ]
up Monday it's slap hamburger on Monday
it's counter it's counter you choke the
bird out Monday down are you Monday [ __ ]
face choke the old bird i watch you -
watch your tone for real hey I'm gonna
like y'all house son in Phoenix you
locked me out of the house and I'm sorry
right you lose all my jaw I had to go
there you caught me a racial slur oh
yeah I'm gonna lock you out of house see
you fry in the Sun baby bird racist what
else you got I think it's also important
to note that back in 2016 this was
actually something that resurfaced for
Mark Wahlberg as well because he was
trying to become an honorary cop or
something and he needed a pardon for the
attack against the venom ease shop owner
and they actually tracked down the owner
and asked him about the situation the
owner said that there were a couple
things that were wrong in the media
people said that
Mark Wahlberg blinded him in one eye
during the attack but it actually isn't
true he was blinded when he still lived
in Vietnam when he was serving in the
Army you know and he also says that Mark
Wahlberg at the time was a young kid not
he personally forgives him he's like we
all deserve that's all that matters that
guy was involved directly with the
situation
yeah so if he and also Mark Wahlberg
made invincible so chill it's like
George Floyd's brother who said I'm
sorry yeah George brother said I'm the
one who's dealing with this if if I'm
not doing violent [ __ ] what are you all
doing any screaming educate yourself
mm-hmm
Rodney King did that same thing to
remember yeah he wanted news that's
right but that was the beginning
[Music]
okay this was submitted by RJ Murray 666
on Twitter what so the Chinese baby boys
gonna get even better yeah Chinese
scientists have found a way that's
currently in the works for them to cure
cauliflower ears non-surgically
Wow and so it says that the technique
involves a digital micromirror device
and bio-ink which is made up of
cartilage cells and different chemicals
it's injected to the back of the ear
after 20 seconds the year the year began
take form may provide a surgery free
option for humans with this condition
who often undergo surgical implantation
that the risk of injury more Briley's 3d
printing technique may open a new avenue
for mounting places Wow 3d printing I
don't know what I would do it I don't
know it's kind of a badge of honor but
people already know you have them or you
had up what's like bride unisol it's
done it's like it's really yeah
can you wear air pods no see that might
be right when I post pics on my bike
rooms like dude I thought you had money
dude you still win wires I'm like yeah I
like the wires do like Haiti err putts
they fall out I lose Oh Nicholas you
wear use wires
hey bro no new UI
I've thrown times richer than you and I
still don't like your four times richer
just as my show got canceled it is it's
actually I'm not happy about a lot of
stuff and that's like I have nothing
good my feeling and that made me do the
pocket surprise for so long oh it's okay
Brian Elon Musk um I'm sorry were you
saying about my money
well do tell my their pods
I can't wave to them they have the
plastic that wraps around what is it man
doesn't work dude he's long on the
trails like this they fall out yeah I
can't afford a bike that's cool I don't
know if I do it like I said I had the
opportunity to go on the BOTS show and
they were gonna fix it listen I had two
surgeries on this air kids got so big
last fighting they said could come off
in a fight Jesus I'd surgery I'm off my
fart yeah it happened to Leslie Smith
I've had my fart this and it's my worst
one I think the guy was a fan it might
have been a dentist he was a big fan
he's like I can figure it out Mike have
you dumped before he's like no but it's
pretty it's pretty up front I can do it
and then I remember this is awful so he
slid open all the blood isn't that
pretty sure but he slid it open with a
knife that felt good my ear was out to
here split it open it all lose doubt he
packed it with like stuff stitch it up I
went about my business for about three
or four weeks on stitch it took the
stitching out well clearly it doesn't
work that way
because the body goes oh there's a
there's a void we got to fill it with
fluid which is what happens sure and
then it hardens and now am I you're
super [ __ ] yeah I suppose I have a
drain right with a syringe that doesn't
that doesn't work let me I've drained I
drained but I used to drain both gonna
have to practice all day in my elbow all
day Alison out of titty I'm elbow
I fight Chris touches her [ __ ] I got
that eyebrows I was in the back with
Greg Jackson I had this huge titty on I
was trying to drain it before I go what
am I gonna do I mean how am I gonna
throw elbows and Greg jessica's what
how many throw was yours have you ever
started on a fight you know he goes who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah you're probably right you'll take
that needle on your elbow all right I
got I got an exact nope don't do that
yes and I thought I was done but it
didn't but I didn't do anything my you
know my cuddle blown you guys got orange
eyes I got my coach goes ah sugar he is
ah sugar that thing blew up like a
[ __ ] basketballs I don't know I
fought through it though then did you
mom go sweetie that's on a broken ankle
- hmm again high school I don't know I
can't remember yes yet
wait is your left you're heavier than
your right does it feel that way no it
does let me ask the question more stuff
that's a little definitely weird yeah
yeah come on it solidifies it some
weight to it
Oh nothing's better dad Joe Cuenco he
does does it affect your hair now huh
dad joke okay so last week dwayne
johnson went on to india and he posted a
eight minute long
IG TV video talking about the George
Floyd situation as well as like
basically asking where's the president
during this time when we need somebody
to unify us as a country it was very
positively received by the internet and
UK bookmakers actually did a survey and
they found that he is the third most
popular option for president behind
Donald Trump and Joe Biden it's just a
popular opinion but yeah it's the rock
what Rock doesn't know about politics
you know not that Trump does well goes
more about the lie I do wish Trump would
be a little more unified me too by the
hopeless like he's just divisive his
house like dude but you didn't do we
can't have a celebrity as your he said
he's thinking about it and offered
20 but he says that it's not real
learning about just Margie 19 wasn't
Schwarzenegger two-term governor I think
her as at one time and he was two-term
got to tournament thank teacher so
Ronald Reagan was a movie star but none
of them took well Arnold was but the
rock I think the only reason why Arnold
didn't run for president is cuz he is
natural-born yeah yeah that's right
otherwise he would have he always had
aspirations to be young
that guy is phenomenal would you vote
for the yeah I don't know his rocks I
have to can you believe we're time let
this be so that's where we're at yeah I
tell you what I vote for the rock over
by day no so what I he might be a better
he might be at least a very you know why
I get it very smart guy probably learn
on a job
I was Oprah running maybe I was I feel
like Oprah Elon Musk everybody's like
these people are practical are very
practical at getting a job for Mark
Cuban I would in a heartbeat yeah
probably you know he was a real snitch
during Corona I don't know what his
politics are I don't know another
problem but I like that he's an economic
stud I like that he's made two
businesses work and done very well
managing a sports team and was he the
PayPal gyeom's or what was he he was in
his fortune and tech but he this is a
mansion [ __ ] yeah so anybody who's that
good at at this image to make you a good
president a manager a good manager
you're innovative if you think outside
the box I don't like I start snitching
on everybody though
he's the biggest [ __ ] turned really
yeah yeah Joe just got looking at all
the Botox on his face that's annoying
d oh yeah he's a vain guy because he
kind of was in the limelight probably
didn't get a lot of girls growing up
there's all that stuff things you gloat
for doing white know why not I think
data formula dollar business to business
I just went to your point yeah Dana
Dana's would probably be a little bit
too much like Trump like as the best
friends yeah he would Dan is the guy who
goes like I there's things that I like
about him with that New York Times guy I
was giving him a hard time because I
don't give a [ __ ]
what that guy thinks then that's great
but Dana is proudly proudly it says if
he just never reads not even long text
yeah
that worries me it's not that Dan is not
smart not that Dana isn't an effective
do we know how many read we know very
well down we don't so I've just I I
think amply roughly legit discussion I
don't think that Dana Rock do you know
why it's not Cuban there's a lot I like
about Dana I just do it smart people are
in politics well because they can
because what happens is the journalists
try to uncover all your dirt all the
skeletons your closet all all the stuff
you were doing when you shouldn't have
been doing it it's also an exhausting
job and the smart minds don't run for
media yeah that's true you've got to be
usually volatile stuff you got to be
really into power you know ok a photo of
Kendall Jenner has been circulating and
a lot of people has have been giving her
[ __ ] on it cuz somebody took this photo
and they actually edited a piece of like
poster paper that says black lives
matter along with a black face mask and
if you click on the photo in the shadow
you clearly see that there's nothing
there
maybe I'm getting older just someone
sent me this house like I don't see the
problem
well now I see the problem yeah so
somebody online took this photo edit it
so many people wanted her yeah this is a
super old photo of her from I think
Instagram someone edited and why did I
start doing this like that there are the
Queen's of social media why she didn't
post somebody did give me her [ __ ]
saying that oh she's doing this to
pretend like black lives matter she
didn't do it she said so she was getting
a lot of [ __ ] for on top of this the day
that a lot of people were posting about
George Floyd she posted up a air pod
sponsorship that she had so a lot of
people were already giving her [ __ ] for
this when this came out people continue
to give her [ __ ] that so much so that
she had to come out cuz a lot of
verified accounts started to give her
[ __ ] about it too and she had to say I
didn't post it somebody edited an old
photo of me to make it look like I'm
protesting black lives matter when you
can clearly see that it's fake she says
that she does and this is even a joke
but it's well documented kadosh Ian's
are very Pro black yes they like
everyone guys they like your yeah yeah
yeah that's right
so I mean is is are we gonna give her a
hard time now to it look it's this is so
hard we're not known like the the
temperature of the society and posting
during the gorge which I did she post on
black Tuesday uh no I think she posted
it the following day it's time because
like I was like like do like or can we
only post about the protests like that
though even the water was a little murky
dives ahead yeah because my point can I
post the podcast can it is it racist if
I don't if I I I don't know what to do
you know can I just went you know what
I'm staying off I'm out
yeah I worry so now well I tell you what
I worry about I worry that we are so
we're like and I think it's gonna die
down but I worry that this momentum
takes on such a fervor that if you're
not 100% on board with everything black
lives matter you lose your job you you
you there's no room for nuance at all
there's no room for to even ask
questions do what we say well that's
gonna do more people more races there's
it there's a for every reaction there
it's gonna make it but the country
memory action there's a reaction and
it's not healthy because if those people
who are on the fence where maybe they
grew up with racist family members and
they're on the fence right now and you
shun them and go get what the [ __ ] dude
then they're gonna go all through Mike
man my grandfather was right
although figure it out Americans always
default I hope you're right right my
worlds on fire you can't you can't be
this crazy Americans figure it out black
Americans white Americans we're in this
dance it's it is what it is thank you
now you're rich or not get off me I
don't like your rich juice on me you
guys know Alexis Ohanian her I don't
he's the co-founder of Reddit
oh yeah he's been a rogue inspector my
podcast he's married to Serena Williams
okay he looks a lot better I see he lost
weight he was in a documentary she did
how's it go
okay well hmm so HemoCue kid he's doing
a big move here I'll just play for you
15 years ago I co-founded reddit as a
place for people to find community and a
sense of belonging it is long overdue to
do the right thing he's still rich I'm
doing this for me for my family and for
my country I'm saying this as a father
who needs to be able to answer his black
daughter when she asks what did you do
so I have resigned as a member of the
reddit Board I've urged them to fill my
seat with a black candidate and I will
use future gains on my reddit stock to
serve the black community chiefly to
curb racial hate and I'm starting with a
pledge of 1 million dollars to Colin
Kaepernick's know your rights camp
that's cool
I believe resignation can actually be an
act of leadership from people in power
right now and to everyone fighting to
fix our broken nation do not stop good
guy powerfully that's a good guy that's
cool
all right I can't help but think do you
think he's a little light in the ass for
Serena willing it's all I think about
he's super talking about he's not tall
it's not that I've spent what no way
he's not that I could have sworn you
might have you know it's all my
anybody's working with something we just
don't know he might have that big he's
our mean Ian and Armenians have got they
got dicks on this is five to six five
pretty tall that's all I'm lying do you
know what I had him on the podcast maybe
I didn't mean it maybe he just did the
podcast Papa he did the Brian Collins
oh he's a big guy ain't it he never did
it I did he didn't know that never in
person no I guess we did it by your
lying
yeah I'm a man being small yeah maybe I
was a guy from ready
loot him there though six five that's a
big guy well she's fine he's got it he's
fine there he's got a piece on nut he's
not lying the earth he's not lighting
the ass at all isn't there another guy
you know Joe hunter Oh
you should watch your back people are
dying for it [ __ ] off Oh Mike you man
come on I mean the fans are demanding
that to come back yeah this here's real
fresh he's got great hair you should see
my dad's here right now
what is the hotel bonito nice it looks
like a VIP member the Grateful Dead
so he takes in his friend I'm gonna say
99% we did it seems like someone that
would be on that show too
yeah we did but I guess he didn't come
in six five that's no joke he's six five
and he's a big Armenian guy he's got
Nate he's plenty man for her
look at that sitting on his lap yeah did
you see my weight do you see my dad's
here my daddy refused to cut his hair
too he sees his grandson my dad looks
like he's been a Grateful Dead member
since the 70s
I mean I'm six five so that's why I said
he's all right I just slouch yeah you
know him on she is yeah we didn't know
I'm sure we do no see if he's already
it's he from Washington DC and a
Redskins fan Washington DC yeah and if
he if that's the case I definitely had
him on 100 watch this he bought he
bought his dad season tickets I asked
him what he did with his money when it
went public or whatever one he sold the
stock the University of Virginia yeah
I'm always from Noodlers from New York
clothes though
dude hold on he's a Redskins fan I'm
just typing his name in Redskins yep
popped up yeah there you go
yep yeah let's his fan who found a bread
we had him on oh yeah we had him on a
long conversation a very nice guy very
good guy you say you're short though six
five I thought I had him on but we had
him on you know what I mean like I had
him calling
all right photos coming up in a sec you
must babies groans hair out for the
quarantine which a lot of people are
doing
that's good hair I mean you know it's
not mine
that's your dad nice and your dad's hair
is very gray silver he has a great hair
though oh dude yeah 64 Wow put that
[ __ ] in a ponytail
does your dad dies hair sometimes I know
Wow hey J do you have to hog the camera
dude Jesus Christ I mean can we get
those teeth filed flat I hope stead of
like that's their cars that they went on
a three-hour drive I've seen I've seen
dollar stays I've seen dollar teeth on a
[ __ ] shark yeah what's with the smile
bro calm down should be short guys short
teeth Oh God tell you what that's
exactly right
shark tup that's a beautiful area where
that is mm-hmm remember Jay does kind of
give me that like finding Nemo shark
vibe though like the friendly charlatan
oh he'll just sit there and stare what's
wrong with you he's just kind of always
kind of taking it in Porsche your family
they'll check out the rides papa and a
little day shot they're [ __ ] love
Jays car which ones which the red jzp3
my papa's is the 911 yes the gt3 and
that would be the red wine yeah okay I
said I said that yeah go you drink
whiskey 2news [ __ ] please God that fool
got his [ __ ] whiskey drinking from me
you think he just picked it up please he
was so mad at me I was I'm sorry
especially with his voice too I'm
smiling too
so Kat actually Tory's leprous got a
good body why wouldn't he be caught um I
wish I was still like that yep so this
morning I saw Chris Cuomo trending and I
didn't know why
apparently his wife was on her I G story
she's doing though I assume so I didn't
really get a good look at her but I'll
look up after this she was doing yoga
and in the back you can see this which
is Chris Cuomo just butt-ass naked in
his backyard spell it's his backyard why
not so like chicas when you have a body
like that why not always seen that CNN
hog now when you have a backyard in New
York yeah that's quite he's if I'll say
a couple things about him number one
he's a thick thick Italian kid number
two I know I'm really back in the day I
know some people who knows me well that
may have slept with him and he's got a
piece on him doing just fine he looks
like a hard worker he's doing very well
there's no Bruce Lee in the sheet I
don't know I've heard otherwise but yeah
a team no tan lines Wow good for him
I've heard otherwise somebody who might
have been my girlfriend to I don't want
to talk about it I don't like being
naked all the time especially in the
backyard like I swim I said just
yesterday I had to take up the shorts
neighbors could see you really want
jaqen well the only reason you don't
like that is because you feel as though
they're gonna be like look at how
biggest body is well no cuz yeah unless
you're unless you're hot that's hot
skirt problems but we took me we do pee
in here together like we do and what I
say - I said dicks looking alright today
you got a good dick game today
I peed in Ojai I peed in the sea hanging
low and didn't think yeah you did
I always feel like a rebel in the sink
and Brian washes in but in the sink well
not like nothing here but we're
basically house angels basically we live
life on the angels we use a sink for
wash house angel had quad there's
prospects what else you had just one
more someone set this to me Jin washes
his face
by the way and tple it's gonna they said
we're gonna march in this place in
California the Hells Angels would said
we'll be there to greet him they
canceled they canceled their check
please yeah all right so someone said to
send I'll just play for you no no oh
please be careful please be careful
it's kind of stuff like that hey that's
really scary the big game set match holy
[ __ ] that's the problem wrong that's not
the problem what's he doing he just
going too fast down that corner probably
and he's not good enough sure I say this
out loud but we don't have the helmet
but he also doesn't look like he's been
biking wrong no he looks I mean he's a
thick boy
yeah that's not yeah ha oh my god yeah
he's he took a little tumble he looks
like he's been missing no meals if no
meals and now he's just sitting there
and during the view you're middle of
nowhere so enjoy that plate back on and
this Instagram accounts called busy wild
is a good one I got a lot of [ __ ] it's
got a few hundred thousand followers or
something like that is it just people
getting [ __ ] up or what I'm not sure
that's not what I saw me well let me let
me see that the other you see there all
right there you go around yeah Lucy a
bunch of those are always gonna see a
bunch of the merry-go-round oh I know
that's a motorcycle well someone's
definitely flying out what so stupid oh
my god they're flying oh I would know
what to do like you passed out
he passed out he's hanging on like it
flexes or he got a hit his head and died
I know oh oh no you found out he
probably passed out for sure that's
Jesus Christ no that's good I'm into
this page now that's good let's see the
golfer please [ __ ] is that
nuts dude oh my god
Jesus Christ god damn that's a good any
is a mullet yeah
Oh amazing shot mmm keep going
[ __ ] up the house no boat no
motorcycle motorcycle looks like it's
gonna be a problem let's see that ooh I
see I see water down
I am very nervous about that
he's pretty confident what's the point
you know you can kind of steered I guess
nah nothing okay let me see that water
what's in the ocean there that scares me
it's be the last the ocean is terrified
is that a couch yeah Murphy loader couch
oh that's like fun I'd love to be in the
ocean right now oh that's not gonna end
well and that captured ads ahead
inflatable couch okay that's hilarious
that's it oh let me see that soldier
with the Cobra enter that's Thailand
you know audio in this one
if that thing bites you in the face
you're done what's he doing this because
you can figure you can figure snakes out
what the [ __ ] Wow what a badass a long
time know is that snake that's why that
was the snake he knows the snake his
hand does yeah still allowed to do that
I've done that couple times oh what's
that barrel thing what about that we're
looking that down in the green crocodile
territory I don't like that don't do
that No
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's fake yes it was just a like an
inflatable alligator yeah it was a
shitty video yeah well now I'm not gonna
follow that page just kidding can I ask
you a question what no I'm in the water
and a crocodile is coming at me
good luck old man you don't jump in no I
would you know I don't know you've had a
good run you know and I get so many more
years to go and have two kids I know if
I'd have kids yeah preju maybe but not
me not Enoch I was like dad Papa crying
I was back what would happen if you
don't what am i landed on a crocodiles
head he's gonna eat me you think so yes
he's not gonna be like what the fog and
you ever see him solo his brothers are
lurking around
yeah they eat you know so you're done
I'm done right you're done I know my
children you'd be too busy I know
nevermind
yeah so much stuff going on well Arizona
we're open up show so those shows that
were all sold out Thursday Friday
Saturday they have tickets now 40
tickets per show open up this Thursday
with there's two shows Friday two shows
Saturday three shows you [ __ ] Phoenix
stand-up live this Thursday Friday
Saturday that's June 11th through the
13th Spokane is all sold out but we are
doing the bike club the first ignarro
thick boy bike club ride Saturday the
27th get the information when you sign
up at thick boy ride at gmail.com Salt
Lake City wise guys July 16th through
18th we're also doing a ride on 18th
year sign up get information the only
way you can find out where the ride is
that is by sign up at thick boy ride at
gmail.com and there you go man this I
can't wait for Phoenix this weekend dude
yes
Phoenix gonna be fantastic come see me
Phoenix obviously still take his left
and in San Antonio Texas I'll beat the
lol company Hotel Emma yep June 25 26 27
I'll see you that everybody all right
this the fine kid route